[Musique]
un souffle
un souffle de cacher ou dans le mystère
de l'océan indien
au royaume du grand bleu
grand bleu ne veut rien dire l'essentiel
de l'eau sion c'est le grand noir les
abysses
[Musique]
dans la nuit éternelle une invitation au
voyage verticale aucun humain n'a jamais
plongé jusqu'ici aucun ni les rendra
jamais sauf dans une machine
[Musique]
pendant des millions d'années les
ténèbres le froid du grand dessous sont
resté une énigme
[Musique]
au pays du calmar géant voici l'histoire
d'un club c'est à ces géants le peuple
du grand noir
[Musique]
les cachalots
et grosse tête et plus gros cerveau du
monde une espèce intelligente et
sociable qui parlent une langue dont mes
mots son déclic
voici cinq siècles l'homme a doublé le
cap des tempêtes et c'est risqué dans
ses parages de terreur qui l'a nommé
quarantièmes rugissants
[Musique]
mais les abysses leur créature lui reste
ignorée
[Musique]
mais caché l'on connaît cet univers
fantastique
il plonge à 3000 m étienne 1h30 en apnée
[Musique]
au dessous de 200 m les humains ne voit
plus que du noir les seules lumières
sont salis créatures bioluminescente
comme cette méduse peigne
nos lampes électriques révèleront
quelques secrets du grand noir
[Musique]
les conditions de vie dans les habits
sont effroyables l'obscurité totale une
eau glaciale entre 0 et 1 degré
cent fois la pression de l'atmosphère à
1000 mètres sous la surface
en l'absence de lumière du soleil pas de
photosynthèse donc pas de plantes au
dessous de 200 m toute créature est
animal
[Musique]
parmi ceux ci le poulpe à oreille
n'hésite pas ses oreilles mais ses
nageoires
[Musique]
à
un prodigieux voyage dans le corps ou
dans le coeur de la mer nous dit c'est à
la fois horizontal et vertical
l'histoire de ce clan de cachalot
commence possible de deux siècles près
d'un archipel perdu de l'océan indien
sur la route de l'antarctique
c'était aussi glaciale et ses ventes et
qu'aucun arbre qui pousse
ici il pleut ou neige 300 jours par an
voici deux siècles une bande de cachalot
malaita buisson paille autour de cet
archipel est grand mal s'accommode des
eaux froides riches en nourriture les
femelles soucieuse du confort de leur
bébé préfère la tiédeur des tropiques le
clan des masses se tient toujours au
large pour une excellente raison que
l'on écoute pas trouvé les pires ennemis
des cachalots
[Musique]
les baleines tueuses
les orques
lors que mal brondy un aileron dorsal
haut d'un mètre quatre-vingt deux fois
moins que sa compagne les orques vivent
troupe familiale d'idées par une femme à
l'expérimenté qu'on appelle la
matriarche
[Musique]
la matriarche a le bon dieu mais vous
encore mieux avec ses oreilles même dans
la nuit du profondeur son art lui offre
une image acoustique précise de
l'environnement
[Musique]
la troupe avant c'était une brigade en
campagne elle patrouille le long des
côtes pour y déceler la moindre activité
par exemple passage des manchots royaux
on en compte deux millions sur
l'archipel
pour nourrir leurs poussins les adultes
effectué d'incessants va et vient entre
la terre et la houle
chez les orques la matriarche a gravé
dans sa mémoire l'itinéraire des oiseaux
les mâles en ont fait autant
[Musique]
les manchots ne manque pas non plus de
mémoire une formule y est inscrite en
lettres de sang orques égale morts
[Musique]
sous l'eau les faibles vibrations des
manchots se confondent avec le vacarme
ambiant pour localiser les oiseaux la
matriarche attend qu'il craint
bruyamment la surface pour respirer
[Musique]
mais hors que sont puissantes jusqu'ici
on n'avait pas compris la manière dont
celles-ci prennent pour dévorer les
manchots les écrase l'oiseau entre
langue et palais afin d'en faire gicler
la chair et les tripes les abandonnent
la carcasse comme un tube de ketchup
vide
la matriarche transmet ce savoir à sa
fille qui deviendra un jour l'âme de la
troupe
[Musique]
voici deux siècles à distance
respectueuse de cette erreur en noir et
blanc les cachalots coup d'une existence
paisible
[Musique]
mais un jour la ligne d'horizon à gauche
de visiteurs inquiétant
ces intrus viennent d'un univers que les
cachalots ne peuvent pas soupçonner ce
sont les hommes bien sûr mais pas
n'importe lesquels partie de la nouvelle
angleterre profession à les nier
[Musique]
les américains ont le lirez ci du
français marion dufresne en 1772 fasciné
par la légende du grand continent
austral se marre un double le cap de
bonne-espérance pas 46 degrés de
latitude sud dans une mer qui décrit
comme grouillante de monstres il trouve
cet archipel il en prend possession pour
la france et lui donne le nom du second
de son navire creuser
[Musique]
les américains mettent à profit la
découverte cet air se vante arctique
trop lointaines pour être surveillés on
les appelle les south semaines les
hommes les mers du sud à l'époque
l'huile de baleine est clair le monde
est quoi
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
là est tout droit devant
on y va histoire
je mangeais nu e
la forme de soufre du cachalot le trail
c'est le seul cétacés qui envoie son
panache par un unique et vend du côté
gauche il ya 45 degrés vers l'avant
par benoît moussaillons avec moi
tribord sûr
toi
[Musique]
des baleiniers savent qu'après chaque
plongée profonde le cachalot a besoin de
dix minutes en surface pour renommer son
oxygène en outre accru ses yeux latéraux
le champ de vision du site assez
présente des angles morts vers l'avant
et vers l'arrière
leur bonheur tente de piquer la baleine
derrière la première bosse de son dos
lavrov mais pour ça longtemps
[Musique]
attention
et
le jeune homme
il a sondé vaut plus d'une heure pour
réapparaître à plusieurs milles d'ici il
en est d'autres pas loin cap au sud
le cachalot isolé appelle ses congénères
à la rescousse les cris d' alerte qui
l'aimé et qu'on qualifie de coda compte
parmi les plus puissants du règne animal
sous l'eau on les entend à des dizaines
de kilomètres
message reçu une centaine de mal
constitue la troupe qu'on pourrait
baptiser le gang de creuser génie
cachalot la solidarité n'est pas un vain
mot
[Musique]
quand l'accord
et
[Musique]
autant de mobilité et déferlant des 40e
rugissants sont durs aussi pour les
baleiniers
c'est à ces écoutes à la fois leur
instinct et leur intelligence le mot
d'ordre est de rester groupé pour se
nourrir comme pour affronter les périls
al'inverse les humains cherchent à
disloquer le clan à isoler un individu
question de patience et l'expérience
[Musique]
lorsque le cachalot dominant est
densifié un danger ils la feront en
combat frontal comme un rival à la
saison des amours en assimilant la
chaloupe à un concurrent celui ci signe
sa perte
aussi longtemps que les cachalots
maintiennent leur cohésion les hommes et
leur esquif ne pèse pas lourd mais en
sondant les gens abandonnent leurs
leaders à une mort inéluctable
et
[Musique]
elle ne bougera pas de la sorte qu'on ne
leur a pas fait la poule
la fin du mois de mars marie à
tous
maintenant vous traduis
harponneur minuit la peau de le pleurer
envoie le haut tiens
là
[Musique]
c'est
autant de moby dick des centaines de
cachalots sont allés sur ses plages pour
y être débité
pouvait fonder leur l'art qu'on met en
tonneaux dans
la langue des marins à cacher lots de
taille moyenne et 1,40 barritt
[Musique]
les baleiniers apprennent aussi à
dépecer leurs prises à flanc de navires
et à traiter la grèce à bord
[Musique]
faute de chez rare dont le grand
massacre s'achève au début du 20e siècle
le gang de creuser a été anéantie il
faut attendre le moratoire de 1986 pour
que la chasse à la baleine soit enfin
prohibé dans l'océan indien comme
ailleurs un royaume que visitent les
descendants des rescapés du massacre
ce qu'on pourrait appeler les sauver les
eaux
[Musique]
dans les abysses le premier maillon de
la chaîne alimentaire tombe de la
surface souvent de débris en tous genres
[Musique]
et
le corps de ce cachalot mord fertilise
les fonds locaux dépouillés par les
baleiniers de sa chair de son l'arrêt du
précieuse paire massetti de sa tête la
carcasse a coulé une aubaine pour les
nettoyeurs
[Musique]
au cimetière des abysses les recycleurs
prospère comme ce corps a eu marre qu'on
dirait fleuri de polypes rose
[Musique]
ce poisson trépied
ce poisson crapaud antarctique
[Musique]
ou ce concombre le maire atypique qui
nagent en pleine eau au lieu de se
traîner sur le sédiment
la masse des détritus nourrit une arme à
la ddt araignées de mer c'est les doigts
yeux se rassemblent par millions
elle attire des prédateurs contre
lesquels elles n'ont d'autre défense ou
leur carapace épineuse
parmi les amateurs de crustacés figure
le grenadier un cousin de la morue sa
queue et fils et lui vaut le sobriquet
de poissons gras
[Musique]
il communique avec ses congénères grâce
à une vessie natatoire qu'il fait
résonner comme un tambour cet organe le
rend vulnérable variations de pression
lié à la profondeur
[Musique]
la chimère dit aussi que de rat est bien
différente elle n'a pas de vessie
natatoire c'est un fossile vivant un
poisson cartilagineux ancestrale proche
des requins
[Musique]
dans la pente abyssal à plus de 500
mètres sous la surface la chimère se
gobergent d'alevins ces petits poissons
compte sur le nombre pour désorienter
leurs prédateurs
pour les alevins le plus terrible ennemi
n'est pas la chimère il possède des
dents acérées de gros yeux qui détecte
le moindre reflet il peut peser 300 kg
et mesurait un mètre quatre-vingt deux
longueurs
ce chasseur implacable c'est la légine
[Musique]
la légine partagé beaucoup de petits
poissons avec le calmar ce dernier
saisit ses proies en projetant vers la
vente de tentacules spécialisés il
arrive aussi que le calmar figurent au
menu de la légine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les cachalots se nourrissent avant tout
de calmars ils les trouvent grâce à leur
sonar
ils émettent des clés que la bo de leur
tête en plus fit élire ij
ce melon contient une ville très fine
appelé sperme à ces petits par les
baleiniers qui l'avait prise pour du
sperme
les ondes sont réfléchies par les
obstacles le cerveau analyse les données
et c'est ainsi que le cachalot pour le
monde avec ses oreilles
[Musique]
d'accord
pour la première fois à la fin du xxème
siècle les cachalots de creuser perçoit
des émissions sonar qui ne proviennent
pas de cétacés
[Musique]
ces cliques sorte de monstre le métal où
ont pris place non pas des baleiniers
mais les scientifiques
des océanographes france est occupée à
lever une carte des reliefs sous-marins
et des abysses les cétacés de crozet
l'eau depuis longtemps dans la tête
en bien plus précis
à certaines époques quelques uns d'entre
eux ont en effet le privilège de gagner
les ont chaud des tropiques où se
tiennent les troupes de femelles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
grâce à l'arrêt de la chasse à la
baleine c'est ici au secret du canal du
mozambique que le goal de crozet s'est
reformé
[Musique]
voici le fief d'une grande femelle une
chef une matriarche entourée de ses
filles petites filles et des jeunes de
la famille au sens large les sociétés de
cachalot matriarcale malgré leurs 18
mètres de longueur et leurs 60 tonnes
contre 12 m et 15 tonnes pour les
femelles les mâles adultes en sont
exclus de temps à autres l'un d'eux un
dominant qui a conquis sa place de haute
lutte vient présenter ses hommages une
belle afin de perpétuer l'espèce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plaisir de la crèche lorsqu'une mère
cachalots sont des pas chassés aux
épices une tente ou une grande soeur
surveille le bébé
les petits apprennent la signification
des clics
décodage des sifflements de leur espèce
qu'ils constituent un langage au même
titre que le code morse des humains ou
les dialogues de tambours des villages
africains
[Musique]
à la puberté le jeu de mal est invité à
oublier la troupe matriarcale tabou de
l'inceste il s'associe avec d'autres
adolescents qui constituent des bandes
de célibataires bacheliers à l'âge
adulte cap au sud vers le royaume de
creuser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui les autres ysern cet
archipel ne résonne plus des cris des
harponneurs comme autant de moby dick
les fonds répercute d'étranges sonorités
métalliques
[Musique]
ces teintes mans attire les autres du
grand noir du moins ceux qui peuvent
nager comme le pool pareil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le restaurant et le menu consistant de
longs fils un gardien dab sont tombés du
ciel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la chimère hésitent devant ces objets
qu'elle n'a jamais rencontrée
[Musique]
même dans le noir le cachalot pu
observer la scène il la voit avec ses
oreilles
[Musique]
des encres en train de faire le font des
kilomètres de long glennie aux palangres
nombreux sont ceux que les hameçons
intéresse
cette offrande tombé de la surface
passionna singulier personnage des
abysses le calmar à braglia
[Musique]
le petit peuple du grand noir se
pressent pour profiter de l'aubaine le
restaurant est ouvert que quelques
heures
[Musique]
les calmars boudent le menu cela leur
sauve la vie
tel ce toutes nos antarctique surnommé
calmars volant et céphalopode se font
rarement prendre au piège
ils entreprennent chaque soir des
migrations verticale de plusieurs
centaines de mètres il gagne la surface
auquel de chair fraîche puis redescendre
à l'aube
le dangereux bons cousins ils totti est
aussi mangeurs de kalma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien n'est jamais simple en mer à
surface le comité d'accueil n'est pas
vraiment amicale
[Musique]
et qui sont donc là haut ce qu'ils
attisent longue ligne
[Musique]
dans leur usine flottante les pêcheurs
travaillent dur vite toujours plus vite
la saison ici courte
oh
afin de ne pas perdre leur ligne dans
l'infini de la houle les marins il un
gain des bouilles muni d'un émetteur
radars
toute cette agitation avec l'attention
des pires ennemis du cachalot
[Musique]
elle détecte un vrai délice à 10000
elles sont curieuses et comprennent tous
très vite elle se parle dans un dialecte
de clic de sifflements et de grincements
[Musique]
les orques les orques arrive menés par
leur matriarche
1 ne consacre que 10 % de leur temps à
chasser le reste se passe on dialogue on
caresse ancien sous en jeu
cette bd corradi ferait un excellent
jouer les croqueuses de manchots ne
plonge pas aussi bien que les cachalots
où l'arrivée des palangriers modifier
les comportements animaux
maëlys attire le petit peuple des 40e
rugissants
peu connu des hommes voici les dauphins
porte croit endémique de ces latitudes
on les appelle aussi sabliers le dessin
de leurs flancs rappelle le symbole du
temps qui passe
[Musique]
dans l'immensité monotone de l'anr tout
devient jeu y compris la rencontre
inopinée de portes croix avec un
sous-marin biologie de la taille d'un
semi-remorque
le grand cachalot
[Musique]
grâce au moratoire sur la chasse à la
baleine une centaine de cachalot mal
jouissent pas nouveau en liberté de
lasauvage splendeur des crozes et ils ne
sont plus contraints de fuir les humains
mais tenter de les suivre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi se demande-t-elle peut-être
faut-il que les orques pointe l'aileron
dans cette harmonie
aurait-elle perdu le goût de manchots
elles ont une réputation du tueuse elle
pourrait attaquer même si leurs grands
cousins sont trois fois plus long et 20
fois plus lourd qu'elle
[Musique]
comme les cachalots elles sont une
centaine à fréquenter l'archipel des
crozet mais elle n'en bouge pas elles
sont sédentaires
pour l'instant ils ignorent leurs
parents c'est assez on dirait qu'elles
attendent quelque chose la matriarche
c'est quoi
[Musique]
elle entraîne sa famille dans le sillage
du navire jusqu'à ce que les marins
repêche à bruit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sitôt celle-ci crocheter la dominante
prend son souffle et descend le long de
la ligne
incroyable les orques inspectent les
palangres des pêcheurs cette fois ci pas
de chance rien sur les hameçons
les offres compris que les hommes et
nice y traquer les proies délicieuse
mais qui vivent bien trop profond pour
elles elles ont la ferme intention d'en
profiter si ce n'est pas l'intelligence
un cachalot aurait pu leur dire qu'il
n'y avait rien sur les leurs
des caches à nous plonge beaucoup mieux
que les orques celle ci s'arrête à 300
mètres en dessous rien à craindre le
cachalot descendent dix fois plus bas
une réduit de rêve aux grands noirs
il
rien au bout des lignes celles journée
pour les palangriers
mais aussi pour les cachalots qui
doivent se rabattre sur un autre navire
on compte jusqu'à six bateaux de pêche à
la fois dans les ondes et creuser
ils ont tous le même silhouette mais
chacun sa couleur
des hommes du président hier les
cachalots zig maïs bien davantage les
heures qui viennent sans vergogne paul
est le fruit de leur travail
seule solution en avant tout est tenté
de semer les pillards d' fût ce au prix
d'un détour de plusieurs dizaines de
milles
problème à peine le palangrier blanc at
il entamé la manoeuvre que déjà les ors
que l'on rejoint elles n'ont pas l'air
de vouloir lâcher prise
[Musique]
sur ses terres de désolation la
dépression s'enchaînent au rythme
effréné de deux ou trois par semaine aux
crozes éléments se déchaînent à plus de
200 kilomètres heure à cette vitesse la
nature remet en question ses propres
lois
les nuages rampe sur la terre
les gars ce cas tourner vers le ciel
et la terre ce phénomène
[Musique]
poussé par des vents d'ouest qu'aucun
obstacle ne freine la grande houle de
l'océan austral tourne tourne autour de
l'antarctique et se déchirent sur les
falaises on avant les plus colossal
vague du monde
les tourbillons aérien apporte aussi de
saint-maurice hauteur de poisson
chacun tente de repérer un bruit
lointain parmi les ondes de tempête
'l'indice d'un restaurant flottant
[Musique]
premier arrivé premier servi les oiseaux
de mer et les orques bien sûr
[Musique]
profitez du travail des palangriers fait
partie de la nouvelle culture d or que
le creuser la matriarche en incarne à la
fois l'instigatrice et l'institutrice
[Musique]
[Rires]
bon
[Musique]
les mâles ne participe à rien le pacha
ne se donnent même pas la peine d'aller
voir il attend surface que les femelles
viennent de mourir
le trésor que les hommes cherchent ici
c'est celui du grand noir des grenadiers
les chimères et surtout les légines les
plus prisées donc les plus chers
jur faste le monstre de métal aval
jusqu'à cinq tonnes de ces poissons
le grand cachalot fini par arriver à son
train
les offres que semble plus agressive que
la fois précédente
deux raisons à cela elin sont maintenant
bien garni et il est seul
la matriarche des orques à la ferme
intention de réserver l'accès du
restaurant à sa famille elle rassemble
sa troupe
le cachalot connaît ce manège cela
s'appelle de l'intimidation
il se place le long du navire un côté
des moins surveillés
[Musique]
dès lors que tente de se glisser entre
le bateau et lui
la matriarche le suivi comme son ombre
pour indiquer sa position à son clan
enfin
stratégie imparable une escouade lui
interdit toute fuite
[Musique]
un matriarche et sa famille déploie le
grand jeu pour ruiner le moral des
adversaires
détonations sous-marine bull crachées
par les vents
le cachalot résiste
mais il est cerné ils essaient de suivre
l'exemple de ses aïeux face aux
baleiniers
il appelle son clan à la rescousse
hélas personne à moins de 10 kilomètres
pour détecter écrit il reste seul
[Musique]
face à la meute on uniforme noir et
blanc sa taille et son poids devienne un
handicap
lors que mal l'empêchent de sonder le
blocus est partout même en dessous
[Musique]
comme le baleinier jadis les orques vise
nombreux morts seule parade tenté le
grand coup de queue pu décrocher
raté elles sont trop rapides trop
nombreuses trop bruyante
[Musique]
on dirait qu'elles ont gagné
reste une carte à jauger en noir profité
d'un instant d'inattention du mal et
sonder le plus profondément possible
[Musique]
six partis
les autres ont pu ce qu'elle voulait
elle fait l'événement
[Musique]
dans la nature les puissants prédateurs
ce défi dépasse rarement à l'acte une
blessure en rien de trop grave
conséquence le cash et lausanne et paris
ce que sa santé pour quelques légine
alors que les abysses lui offre
généreusement les deux tonnes de
nourriture et il a besoin chaque jour
les palangriers peuvent le remercier il
a un peu retardé le pillage mais le
banquet deshors que recommence
[Musique]
les orques font même la fine bouche
lorsque la légine n'est pas au menu
[Musique]
et voici le dessert du pacha
une récompense le guettait d'autres
profiteurs comme ces pétrels à menton
blanc
[Applaudissements]
les poissons à bissau ne font pas partie
du régime alimentaire normal des orques
ou les oiseaux marins comme le pétrel
géant ou l'albatros royal en jetant ses
palangre dans le grand noir l'homme
bouleverse la donne écologique
nombre de locataires de mer australe ont
modifié leur comportement pour accéder à
cette manne
le bateau de pêche devient une oasis
artificiel pour opportuniste et
charognards une sorte de fontaine
miraculeuse de protéines
[Musique]
cela peut-il durer mme est il possible
de briser ou de raccourcir une chaîne
écologique majeure sans en payer le prix
dans les eaux des creuser des quotas de
pêche ont été instaurées encore faut-il
se donner les moyens d'empêcher le
braconnage
[Musique]
quant aux cachalots rien ne prouve
qu'ils sont innocents de tout chapardage
sur les longues lignes secret bien gardé
si le cachalot pouvait parler et il
parle dans sa langue cliqueter il dirait
qu'il a d'autres secrets a confié en
tant que membre du club très fermé des
visiteurs du grand noir il observe que
les équilibres écologiques change très
vite dans les profondeurs
des tonnes de légine en moins dans les
abysses c'est autant de menaces envolé
pour les calmars les mollusques peuvent
se reproduire vieillir tranquille et
atteindre des dimensions colossales
à l'exemple de ceux conatus le plus
grand c'est à l'open jamais filmé vivant
dans son milieu
[Musique]
longue de 30 cm les coquilles de clape
ce géant de l'arrière-plan permettent
d'estimer la taille du mollusque à 3
mètres 50
[Musique]
oh
vous creusez des palangriers récolte de
6500 tonnes de légine par an
les quelques son cachet lot de
l'archipel engloutissent dix fois plus
de nourriture
entre autres cette chimère à londres au
str
ou cette autre gonna tus
on l'a découvert dans l'estomac des
cachalots des animaux surarmés comme le
poisson vipère mais pas la moindre trace
de blessures sur la proie cela signifie
que les grands cétacés capturent leurs
proies en émettant des trains de clic
d'une telle intensité que celle ci reste
cloué sur place le cachalot les une arme
absolue le cri qui tue
c'est un des secrets du grand noir
de sedan les hommes tomberont jamais
parlé parce qu'ils appartiennent à notre
monde
[Musique]